so I'll continue with the tour of more
applications of communication but before
I do that I want to make a few comments
about this proof because several of you
so many interesting things during the
break first I could I pointed out that
this proof actually appears in a paper
by clock which I didn't know about so
should be yeah and the second is that
two people Ryan and she can't both
independently suggested a different way
to view the same protocol which which is
nice so let me just say what that is so
one way to think about what's happening
in this protocol is you know so Alice
has this input
she doesn't know some of the value of
the input bits here but she knows most
of them so she needs to send a message
to Bob so he can compute this function
so what she can do is just evaluate this
formula as much as possible so she takes
our input and just plugs in the values
that she does know evaluate the formula
as much as possible she'll end up with a
smaller formula this is kind of like
shrinkage right and in this formula
there will be some gates which which
have only one input coming in to them
but those can be just eliminated it
doesn't make sense to have a unary gate
so in the end you end up with just a
really a formula then you just describe
else can just describe this formula but
this also would give the same parameters
and it's basically the same proof but
maybe it's nicer
so that's about an inch port and and the
next result that I want to talk about is
I want to prove a lower bound on monitor
on circuits this is something that again
feybelle alluded to in stock proof
complexity so let me remind you what the
model is and then we'll prove the nice
lower bound so the model monotone
circuits so here every every gate here
you know you're only allowed and in four
gates so every gate computes either at
the end of its inputs or the or of its
inputs so such a such a thing can only
compute monitoring functions and the
lower bound I want to prove is a result
of rosin Winterson which also builds and
I guess work of car shrugs and weakness
and and and Kershner and Winterson and
what they prove is that matching
requires
Omega n death so I'll say what that that
means what is matching so the input to
the matching problem is a graph then
you're trying to figure out is does the
graph have a large matching okay so
match up gee-gees a graph and it's one
if G has a large matching and for the
purpose of the proof
I think the parameter that I'll need is
the matching of sy we've been looking
for matching the size roughly n over
three so the graph has n vertices and
you know does the graph of the matching
of size roughly a know with you see in
the proof and otherwise you're supposed
to put 0 now this is certainly a
monotone function meaning that as you
add edges to a graph you can you know
once it contains a matching it can all
me
continues to contain the matching so it
can be computed by a monotone circuit of
this type and what we're going to prove
is that such a circuit any such circuit
must have Omega n depth there is no
shallow circuit that computes
there is a model clear and the problem
okay so as usual we will release the
communication and again it will be these
are both sort of circuit models but the
reduction to communication will be very
different
we'll use a reduction a kind of a
connection that was discovered by cosmo
andersen and then specialized to the
case of monotone
circuits by car Shiraz and we derson so
so here's a key idea so let me let me
just tell you how you can go from a
circuit to a protocol and then we'll see
will will try to prove that that
protocol must have large so how do you
go from a circuit to protocol so here's
the natural thing you can do so suppose
suppose you somehow construct so here's
here's something that Alice and get Bob
can do with such a circuit okay a low
depth circuit so suppose Alice has a
graph
this lethargy that has that has the
matching has a large matching
and bob has a graph that does not have
matching
then what what else and bug can do is
they can use this circuit so these cats
cannot be the same right but not only
can they not be the same this graph must
have an edge that's not in this graph it
cannot be that H contains all the edges
of G otherwise it would contain the
matching and this circuit allows Alice
and Bob to find such an edge so they can
simply communicate to find an edge e
that's in G but he is not in H and how
will they do that it's a very simple
reduction they both know the circuit
okay they both know the circuit so Alice
will plug in the edges of G in the
inputs and Bob will plug in the edges of
H and for you know this circuit will
output you know this gate here will
output you know f of g equals 1 and or a
match of G over here it's F it computes
on function and that function evaluates
to 1 on G and on HSN value to 0 but now
this is a NAND gate right so the end of
the two things feeding into it for G
must be 1 so here you know you must have
if this computes a function G you have G
of G is equal to 1 and this can be H of
H of G equals 1 on the other hand the
end of these two must be 0 for Bob so
one of these gates must evaluate to 0
for Bob so you must have say H of H
so Bob can send just one bit to Alice to
indicate which of the which of the gates
has this pattern one zero and now we're
exactly in the same situation as before
this is the whole reduction so Bob just
sells they both evaluated their circuit
then we know that the output of the
circuit is different for both of their
inputs so that means one of the inputs
feeding it must be different but not
only that it must be the case that
there's some input some gate feeding
into the output gate where Alice sees a
1 in box is 0 so Bob will communicate in
this case Bob will communicate it with a
NAND gate if it's an or gate Alice will
send one bit to indicate where the
differences between them but they just
keep doing this and after they do this
if the circuit has depth D after they do
it for D steps they will reach an input
and the input will be exactly some
variable that's you know a bit
indicating the presence of an edge and
that's exactly what they want they will
find Alice will find that the edges in
her graph and Bob will find the de edge
is not in this graph
so any circuit of depth D gives actually
a protocol here with communication is
you know exactly Dean with after
communicating D bits you can you can
solve this problem and now I want to
show you that you must you must set
Omega n bits to solve this problem yeah
so this proof is really interesting and
one of the reasons it's interesting is
for for the reason that you you just
brought it so this is about
deterministic protocols but actually now
to prove the lower bounds I'm going to
appeal to randomized communication
complexity so it's kind of a strange and
tricky reduction
so far it's just about deterministic
protocols but now I need to prove this
lower bond and I will actually reduce
this problem I will show that they can
use this protocol to get a randomized
protocol for this chiness that's how I
prove the robot yeah here I just assume
that the fan is too but if the fan is
larger you know you cannot you with a
small blow up you can always make the
fan to give you a or gate of as long as
this size any other comments yeah where
did I need okay so what happens in the
circuit is not monotone does someone
else see where I use in monotone
everybody but you're both right so the
problem is if it's not monotone it could
be that these two have different values
but here the value is 0-1 you know it
could be that H of G is zero and this is
this day so you know if the final value
is different one of the inputs must have
a different value but it doesn't need to
differ in this specific way where the
output on G is 1 and the output on
ageism yeah so so if I was looking for
just that there's an edge where there's
a difference between G and H I didn't
need that the circuit is monotone look
but I want that actually the edge should
be in G and not in each specific
difference and somehow that difference
is the difference between monitor the
city and exactly yeah
yeah so the same connection does work
for non monotone circuits as well that's
a car summer Gerson game and you can use
that connection to prove some lower
bonds but this is an even stronger kind
of protocol it's not just finding a
difference in the inputs but this kind
of difference and we'll use that
so you mentioned you're gonna use the
one thing that makes the non monotonic
it's more challenging is that there it
always is a randomized protocol that's
also very that's right is that also true
for the mother to in case hmm
no I don't think it's true for the model
to in case I mean that's what yeah
that's why we're able to so yeah so what
Russell is saying is that suppose I just
wanted to find an input where the values
are different rather than being
different in this specific way so then
you know I can just ignore the circuit
there's always a cheap protocol a
randomized vertical cheap randomized
protocol do that I just have two binary
strings which are different and I want
to find one input bit that's different
you can just use hashing and binary
search to find this bit okay so this
will give you a cheap randomized
protocol to find a bit so it's somehow
then lower bonds there's no lower bound
communication so you can't use that
approach on randomized protocols to say
anything but but here this protocol it
has to find basically only a 1-0 in the
difference and there's no randomize
protocol that can do that cheaply so the
bad thing that could happen is use
hashing and every time you find zero one
zero one you never find a witness that's
of the type one zero
or questions that are coming
okay good so so that's now I want to
prove that this communication protocol
requires so this is I want want to prove
that Omega and bits required are
required
and the way that I'm going to do that is
by reduction to the communication
complexity of disjointness so let me
show you how the reduction works first
I'll show you deterministic reductions
it doesn't work and then we'll try to
patch it up so so say Alice and Bob have
sets x and y from some universe so and
they want to compute they want to know
are these sets disjoint or not the
question you want to solve and we know
we know that this requires Omega n
communication even for randomized
protocols
this is that's one of the most important
results in communication Quebec City oh
yes okay you need Lily linear bits of
communication sprue first bicolor
kalyanasundaram and [ __ ] Shin Edgar
and then Roz Bravo I've had a very nice
proof and then there's they've been
several they've been several other
proofs that have come since then okay so
that's the problem I'm going to show
that if you can solve this problem then
you can solve this problem so how does
it work it's just sort of like one of
these np-completeness gadget reductions
so here's what it looks like so here's a
set X I'm going to write the indicator
vector for X and then describe two
graphs right what I want to show is
Alice will take this X and map it to a
graph this graph will have a large
matching Bob will take his his side and
map it to a graph and this graph will
not have a large matching and then they
will run that protocol and somehow the
output of that protocol will tell them
whether or not these sets are disjoint
so let's look at let's look at the
indicator vector for X&Y okay and so
it's zero one so here's what Alice's
graph would look like so if she sees ero
she will go like this they're gonna be
three vertices here and if she sees one
she will go to the right
and what is Bob gonna do so Bob let's
say he sees
what about this so I've actually used
Bob's input to pick a set of vertices
and what what Bob's the the graph G is
exactly this this is G and H is the set
of edges touching the squares actually
so there's what I need to patch this up
so there's one more edge that G has all
right this is the reduction so let's see
let's see what it does
so first G is exactly the matching the
the size of the matching is M plus 1 for
every input bit in in else's input
there's an edge okay and then there's
one extra edge that I've added here so G
has certainly it has the matching of M
plus 1 it is a matching of size M plus 1
and what is y Y has actually way more
edges so why the input to Bob determines
M vertices and it's all the edges that
touch these vertices all edges that
touch to the back two vertices so in
particular why does not have a matching
of size M plus 1
you don't see their I haven't drawn the
edges of sorry H does not have a
matching of size n plus one so you see
it's a really rough on the squares no it
is the complete graph on the squares and
more it has also you know this edge is
in H this has edges in H this edges in H
these dotted edges are all in H but it
has many more it's all edges all every
edge that touches the square is in each
in the yes in there yes every pair of
vertices that that intersects square is
an edge in H and these are exactly the
edges every H must stretch a square area
H must touch a square an edge is
included in H if and only if it touches
the square which is or not in age so for
example there's this edge is not an H
from these two because it goes from non
square to non square completely no it's
like me to draw a picture so this is
these are the squares and then this is
an independent set in H here you have a
complete graph and then all the edges
from here included but
to drop the diluting Scuttler of size
and exactly yeah and that's the proof
the point the point is okay first is the
definition of the graph okay now H
cannot have a matching of size n plus 1
because every you know every edge that
you include the matching has to touch a
square and a distinct square right
because the matchings are disjoint so
there are only n squares here so you
cannot have n plus 1
it isn't match
moreover what happens when you have an
intersection between these sets so the
way it's defined it relates right so the
H always you know goes to the bottom
left or top right the X always is like
this or like this so the feature of this
is that when you have an intersecting
input which happens here this square
does not touch this edge in all other
cases the square touches edge okay in
other words this edge is not in H this
edge is not in age but this edge is not
in H so the idea would be so this is and
this exactly corresponds to an
intersection so the edge that's not in
that's an in in G but not an H here
corresponds to the intersection except
for the last stage and and that's that's
where that's why this is not yet a proof
so the problem is there's also another
edge this one which is also in G but not
in each there are two at least two they
could be more but there's this one so
the first idea for reduction is you know
Alice and Bob do this they get G and H
now they just run the protocol they find
an H find an edge that's in G but not H
if they're lucky it'll be this one if
their sets intersect right if they're
set they're disjoint
they will this is the only one that
could be output but you would hope
somehow that this is the one you will
see and if you see this one then then
then you're you know the sets intersect
but the problem is that it could be that
your protocol always just outputs this
edge which gives you no information it's
not a witness to them being disjoin
[Music]
doesn't know if they want yes exactly
yeah so the the fix is that what they
will do it so the this construction is
another nice feature which is that when
the sets intersect when x and y
intersect this edge is sort of
indistinguishable from this edge well
what I mean by that is that if you pick
a completely random permutation like and
then feed me the graph after the random
permutation I can't tell this edge apart
from this edge structurally there's
there's no difference between them right
if you just look at the picture they're
a bunch of edges that touch squares
those will stay remaining touching those
same squares but this thing will go to
some random place and is the same
distribution as this thing okay so once
you randomly permute this picture the
information the the protocol so here's
what you here's what else involve
actually do they take their X&Y they
construct these then they randomly
permute this graph but they know they
both know what the permutation is so
they use shared randomness to pick
uniformly random permutation per mutable
graph but this protocol it doesn't know
what the permutation is so the chance
that it outputs this edge has to be the
same as the chance that outputs this
edge yeah so it'll if there is an
intersection it'll output that
intersection it'll output an
intersecting edge with probability at
least half and after you see the edge
that was output you can you know
reverse-engineer the permutation to
figure out whether it was one of these
or one of these so that's so the whole
protocol so you you just repeat this
process so you you construct this graph
randomly permute them run that protocol
maybe you get this edge so you don't
stop you you do it again you again
permute the graph and you run it again
and if you see this edge over and over
then it must be that the sets are
disjoint but if there is some
intersection then with high probability
after a few iterations you will see an
edge that comes from here
yeah does the same work for bipartite
matching and if I can prove or disprove
any other questions there are comments
and so I related what were perfect
matchings do we have otherwise this is
the only reduction yeah I know there's
also a pebble actually in his dog
disgust reduction not to matching but to
click versus covering and I'll leave it
to you as an exercise in this picture
you have everything you need to do also
click purchase coloring you will use
three vertices in each thing then you
will do something different from that
point on but you will randomly permute
and do something yeah what if you take
the graph and you add T new nodes that
are connected to every other no I think
that needs to take up the slack and you
make them connected to each other as
well so these can take up the slack as
they can perfect match
oh we're trying to do a perfect matching
yeah oh I see I see
ok I see so you're saying you have a set
here that are connected to yeah oh and
over three and these are connected to
everything so right so yeah
yes actually this is a yeah this is the
same yeah a similar idea shows up in the
streaming
oh it is okay oh and binding okay
yeah just a small of depression that you
instructed the Pisan page then even
though she is an edge of a cousin she
would be should be smaller than a
indication because otherwise somehow
always right yeah yeah so I'm insurance
observationally want such a reduction
you have to have that the the one of the
function has to have lower hanging
weights has a fewer ones than the then
the zero of the function because
otherwise there is a protocol just
binary search right so so when thinking
about such reductions
you know if G has always more edges than
H then there is a protocol to solve the
problem so it's a hard distribution you
sort of are looking for this hard thing
where G has actually very few edges
which is what happens here H has many
more edges but G has a structure that H
does not have
it's complete on the mainland many
demand maximum you can always do some
matching and H can be the complete yeah
completion without imagine not sure you
maximal graph without imagine oh I think
okay you're saying so instead of this
age you could have just picked it is
actually in my but it is yeah it's
already it's the maximum graph where the
boxes are the vertex cover right yeah
which is yeah okay good
so let me what was I going to talk about
next
have several options
so I want to it's a crime if I don't
show you something about data structures
so that's what I will do so I'm going to
show you a very interesting lower bound
on data structures but I think I will
try to navigate a level of formality
that's that allowed me to communicate
the ideas but not get stuck doing a ton
of calculations so you'll have to be a
little more forgiving of the details
here trust that they work but I want to
show you the key so so now you know
we're leaving the world of circuits and
I want to tell you about how you can use
communication to study something about
data structures prove lower bounds and
data structures so first what is the
data structure I'll be talking about
static data structures
and give you definitions I'll just give
you an example so here's the problem
that I'm going to be interested in
explain what a data structure for that
problem is so the problem that I'm going
to study is is this is a one of the
fundamental problems in native
structures it's called predecessors
search so here's here's the problem you
have some Universal size N and there's a
subset s and you want to sell out store
the subset in in somehow in a way so
that later you can efficiently compute
the predecessors of this subset so you
take this subset and you encode it using
an array this is the data structure and
actually let me call this T
and right here s which is the size of
the array is the space used by the data
structure and usually there's a
parameter W which is the number of bits
stored in each location and what what
the predecessor search asks for is at
runtime you will be given some input X
in N and you want to compute the
predecessor of X predecessor of X is
just the largest element of s that is at
most X of T that is at most X so it's a
maximum over all the elements that are
at most X and yes
this is a predecessor of X
so the game is somehow encode this the
the set T store it using a few bits and
so that you can later quickly compute
the predecessor of any predecessors it
has to be an element of this set T and
it's the largest one that's at most X
the first element you start from X and
start walking back and the first element
that you see that's inside T is the one
you want to output and what we care
about is we want this space used here to
be small and we want the running time
used to compute P of X also be small
we're here the running time is just a
number of queries made into this data
structure
okay so let's let's talk about two sort
of trivial algorithms that you can you
can do what one trivial algorithm is
just write down T right it's indicator
vector just store it sort of in the cure
this will take only n bits to encode T
so just reuse the indicator vector
it's order it it just takes n bits to
store it but then the time you might
take to answer such a query it might be
really large because you may be the the
natural algorithms you just go you know
you'd go to location X in the bit vector
if that's a 1 you output X but otherwise
you need to start walking back until you
see the first one but that could take
linear in your time it could be could be
time in that's not too great another
another option if you really care about
having the time be really fast is is
just you know store all crazy so
basically you maintain a huge table okay
where s is
oh actually no it's only an login right
all right it's N and log of Edward words
and then word Edwards and each one is
his logging
a new political actually I'm just
thinking I realize now that for for it
for this problem to make sense I think
about set small sets yes which is the
detail that I thought I could loss over
but now I see that I cannot so so
actually the yes and in the problem here
this the the size of T is also bonded
we should at least have like a third
trivial solution just like a binary
search tree yes yeah so you can also do
so here T becomes one so maybe so this
this so this this trivial solution is
just you store you pre compute all the
values P of X okay ahead of time and
just store them and then you can look
them up and in general this is something
you do for any day to start your problem
on this type you know you look pre
computed every possible query they could
be asked and store this value but here
it actually didn't cost that much but in
general problems you know if the input
here is large that would be extremely
expensive yeah but you you really want
in this case to be have storage around K
or K low so yeah these are both
expensive when Kane's indicator vector
you have a list of elements yeah yeah
actually yeah you're right
yeah the trivial solution here should be
like K log n or no yeah yeah K log n
right a sorted list and then you would
need to you know K let's not worry about
it
so detracting from yet so the trivial
solution is there's there's something
else that you can do that's easier but
there is a really the right there is a
beautiful data structure that solves
this problem and it's a very clever it's
called venom divorce tree
and it has these parameters so we can
have s that's like a log log n right
probably a lot of fudging going on here
and T is also log log N
each each word will be login okay so
this is not so k log n bits are required
to store the justice set okay that's the
setup sighs okay just to encode the set
and this uses another log log in
additional factor and then it's able to
answer queries really fast in log log n
time what did I do something wrong
I've written things in a way that's
different from how people usually
explain them in order to make them
translate well to communication but I
may have made something anyway that it's
like I said you know let's not worry too
much about the parameters the the main
thing I want to communicate is how this
relates the communication and how you
can reason about this thing which seems
to have it's not immediately it seemed
like as a communication protocol on it
using communication protocols so let's
let's talk about that so in fact this
protocol this this this data structure
is type I've heard the static case well
it's tight up to a log-log up to lower
order checks right if you you can get
better time with marginally larger space
like k to the 1 plus epsilon this space
you can get a little better time right
if then if the space is right so okay
yeah so yeah there's some sense in which
this data structures type you cannot
strictly improve all the parameters
that's that's the maybe the cam that can
be made but there's many parameters here
so there's a trade-off okay but I guess
what Paul is saying is that if s is
maintained to be like this you cannot
have T to be substantially smaller I
think the lower bound says T must be at
least log log n over log log log n or
maybe even that even with polynomial
okay but if you want this K log log n
this is tight okay but again I'm not
going to so that's a work of I tie and
then Paul and fish
and then Roscoe and Thorpe have
subsequent work on it
there's a sequence of papers analyzing
this and showing that this data
structure is divided data structure and
I want to say that there are many nice
open problems here that we don't you
know this is a natural problem but there
are other natural problems for which we
we don't have tight lower bonds but I
guess see will there's a whole workshop
on this subject so you'll see more about
that but let's now talk about how you
can use communication complexity to
reason about this problem or any data
start your problem and the idea is less
than 750 will be so much yeah so if I
actually haven't been able to for me so
it's the the the theorem looks something
like it looks like something like either
T is I actually didn't write down yeah
we maybe say something it's not
satisfying to you either T's like this
or s is like this this is roughly what
it looks like and W is the parameter
that shows up here so there's some
trade-off between these two and they're
sort of terms that depend on W in this
so these kinds of results are sort of
clunky because there are so many
parameters but often the tree there's a
often they're expressed in terms of
trade-off between time and space
okay so let's not worry too much about
the calculations but let's see how you
can use communication to to understand
this so there is a communication
protocol hiding in here and and that's
this one so suppose you have such a data
structure and it has those parameters
then just take consider the the problem
where Alice has X and Bob has T and they
want to just compute this predecessor
the function here is exactly the same as
what the data structure is asking you to
evaluate but what you get from any such
data structure is a protocol and that
protocol looks like this in the first
step you know this algorithm that makes
T queries it goes to some location in
this data structure right so what Bob
will do is Bob knows of all set T so he
will compute this array compute all the
entries in this array and Alice has an X
so what Alice will send Bob is just log
s bits that indicate where she wants to
make a query in video structure log s
bits that will tell Bob that Alice look
is looking at this location and Bob will
respond with W bits that indicate that
say what the contents of that cell are
what the contents of that area locations
and that's it so they just repeat this T
times
Alice is basically executing the
algorithm of the data structure but
she's not sending Bob X she's just
sending the locations of equation bob is
responding with the contents of their
hurry yeah what is an adaptive yes yeah
yeah the algorithm here is allowed to be
adaptive
so the algorithm looks a bit you know
location by location and decides where
to look next based on where you look
okay so if you can prove a lower bound
on this communication game you prove a
lower bound on the data structure this
is actually a meaningful reduction the
data structure is significantly weaker
than a communication protocol because
sort of in communication protocols Bob's
response here in this round can depend
on the messages that were sent before
but in data structures bob has a fixed
response for every every query made by
house ok so there's a loss when you go
from protocols are much stronger than
data structures so the response to space
almost s to the
by the time you're done with the teeth
question butter Tino gets possibility so
there are t no no exponential family
right so so that's that's making an S to
the team busting it's basically in the
what once yo the whole protocol in a
table we're given the conversation so
far which is gonna be a pine log s times
T yes you can simulate so the protocol
is between space a spiky and space s to
the T and T I'm not sure whether that's
yeah that's yeah that's exactly one one
loss that happens for this kind of thing
is that this means in this so in this
protocol you know you'll never be able
to prove there's a trivial protocol
where Alice sends just X Alice Sensex
this is a trivial protocol so the lower
bound you can prove can never exceed
that because after Alice's after they've
communicated long enough so the number
of bits here is just encodes X then in
in protic in the protocol world Bob can
just know X and that's the end of the
communication but in the data structure
world it doesn't help you know that that
upper bond doesn't have an analog
so this is where you can there's a limit
to how strong the data structure lower
bonds you can prove in this way are does
it have the analog of if you've got you
know if you know the number of exes
number of queries you could P process
and store every possible answer to every
possible party that's the same it's the
same that's the same with a single query
but when the queries are large
it's when you have one query you know
Bob sees everything that was said that's
okay but when T is large that's when the
data structures become weaker because
Bob doesn't have memory to remember what
was said before
okay so alright probably be the last
topic that I will talk about see so I
just want to give intuition for how you
prove this lower bound it goes it go the
way it goes is that the proof is
inductive okay uses what's called round
elimination in literature and so let me
just show you a key step so the the the
way the proof works is by induction on
the number of rounds of communication
here so there's zero runs of
communication if there no message being
sent and the whole thing is trivial
there's no way to compute this thing and
now what we want to do is we want to say
that if you have a protocol that has
some number of rounds of communication
you can effectively eliminate one of the
messages the first one the first message
and get a protocol for that has one
fewer round of communication solving the
same same problem so
so let me show you how to eliminate one
run
so suppose you have suppose you have a
tea round protocol a protocol that looks
like that and Alice sends his first
message and log s bits the way the proof
works is you you by induction you design
a hard distribution on inputs to this
problem where any protocol with this
many rounds with one fewer rounds of
communication must fail must make an
error to do by induction and now I want
to show that having this one more
message also doesn't let you solve this
problem so you first so by induction
there's some distribution everything
every everything actually the way can do
this proof is by thinking of the
submissions on input so actually will
prove the stronger fact that there's a
distribution on elements X and sets T
where such a protocol must make an error
if it's too cheap so there's a
distribution on X and T where the
protocol makes protocol with once you
around
watch fewer messages makes an error
it's a good probability bear and now I
want to take that distribution and make
from it a new distribution on inputs
where even this protocol will make
errors of good probability and the
intuition is basically we'll make it
look like alice is sending this first
message and we'll make it look like
actually Alice's input can be thought of
as many independent inputs and only one
of them is important okay but Alice
doesn't know which one of them is
important and that's how we'll get the
doorbot so now I'll just write down what
they do so the heart distribution so
let's say this distribution so I'm gonna
construct a new heart distribution looks
like this you will take
our independent samples
and those samples let me write them as X
1 X 2 X R and then we have the sets s1
s2
each of these is is independent but X
and s might be coordinated next one is
coordinated with a salon x2 is oh sorry
t sets our t1 through TR
and here our will be chosen so that it's
much bigger than a log of s it's much
bigger than the length of this message
okay so so now what are the inputs to
Allison above the new input cells and
Bob the new X will be just the
concatenation of X 1 through X R so just
look at the bits of the bits of X will
just be the concatenation of the big
bits of X 1 to XR
so the most significant bits of X will
come from x1 the next most significant
bits of X will come from x2 so in this
way I've combined these numbers into one
number and this is a number from a
bigger universe so I'm sort of changing
the parameters of the problem that's
okay so these are the bits of X and the
bits of s bits of teak or the set T is
going to look like this so we'll also
pick uniformly random eye from our
maybe I'll write x is just the
concatenation
and then let I be a uniformly random
coordinate goal is so that that
determines which x iu really I want to
ask exactly yes yeah so I want to say
that in the final problem that I make
only one of these X's will be relevant
and that'll be X I okay now I need to
construct the set T so that's true only
with zeros so T I need to make the most
significant bits here up to the ithe one
irrelevant right so how do I make them
irrelevant every element of T is going
to have the same more significant bits
and then in the ice block the the
elements will come from T sub I and then
the helmets afterwards you can just set
them to do so this is T so you write it
pictorially or not where it's formulas
so T every element that belongs to T
looks like this it has exactly the same
values in X 1 through X I minus 1 here
it's an element of T sub I and here at
zeros
and they're going to put the make the
bids in the front random or something
well they have to match up with what
else has so I can't reveal to Ellis what
I is so from else's perspective
everything has to be exactly identically
distributed so these also have to be in
the same way yes the crucial thing is
this reduction is only when alice is
sending this message this is the message
I'm eliminating okay and when I'm
eliminating Bob's message I will do a
different introduction okay but what's
out of time so I'll just say what the
intuition here is what you can do using
information theory is show that so now
these are the inputs right so what's
happening here is that the predecessor
here of X of X in T is basically
determined is by the predecessor of X I
and T I because the first I minus
wouldn't bits of all the numbers in this
thing are exactly the same the first I
minus 1 blocks the only that block is
important that's the first thing so if
you can compute this predecessor you
compute that look but Alice has no
information about I what she sees is
just this they're all identically
distributed there's no information about
I Bob knows exactly what I is but he's
not the one who's speaking right now so
Alice is sending this message and the
the intuition is that because this
message is has fewer bits than the
number of coordinates there'll be one
coordinate where she reveals very little
information much less than one bit of
information
the average score the average
coordinates should reveal very less
information so that's the intuition so
then you can fix her message and fix all
of this and you get a reduction to a
protocol that solves the problem on just
this ice block and this first message
didn't help at all no information about
that block that's the intuition maybe
I'll leave it as exercise so this is
this reduction but if you want to
eliminate a message from Bob you do
exactly the same thing you need to do a
different operation now you want I to be
known only to else actually it's even
simpler in that case so maybe I'm just
right so the the way you actually think
of the universe
are you yeah you you suppose this is the
universe you think of X as having a
pointer into the ayat' part of the
universe this is X I and Bob has sets
these are not the indicator vectors of
the sets it looked like t1 t2 another
reduction so Bob you know views their
set and takes a disjoint union of his
sets but actually only the ID set
matters he doesn't know which which one
is I'd said and Alice just has a number
from that I've said so it's the same
thing you take independent samples but
now Alice knows which Gordon is relevant
and Bob doesn't know so you can
eliminate the next round of message with
the same intuition about Kate it does
increase it yeah well so you then you
have to do a computation of the
parameters to show you you still you get
you get some lower bound for a different
value of K and this K is growing so you
need to control Howard so it's a
complicated calculation but you then
need to make sure it's not going too
fast and then you can still get
something yeah so I think here the W is
going to be much larger than the log s
right so Bob's messages are going to be
yeah yeah I guess so yes it has to be
like holly NJ yeah I don't
it sounds like you understand it well so
the in the argument are there like
parameters that you'd be based on the
relative sizes of f8w so that though in
the argument the only parameters well I
think the only thing you need to worry
about is you need to set our to be
bigger than log s and the error that you
get from this argument should be good
enough to apply for T ron's so this is
how you choose the size of these
universes and then then you need to sort
of calculate what lower bond you get for
every checking of STW this is I don't
have any more intuition then than that
if you have one for example and if
previously you had n as the universe
eyes after one round it's going to be
like n to the log is no and to the W
would be much worse than n to the log n
yeah
so wondering if there's some way of
favoring that by regulation of this is
that don't the parameter W actually
doesn't you know it does it depends
rather weakly on the parameter W like
the lower bound works for a wide range
of W don't have to do that it's bounty
Lohan yeah even if it's like 2 to the
log to the 1 minus Epsilon ok
okay so it's nothing
[Applause]